so a lot of people
ask me about uh like what's uh joe
rogan's jiu jitsu game like
like like like assuming that i somehow
spend uh hours rolling the before and
after
i mean what's a good uh we you should at
some point
show a technique or something that'll be
fun sure i mean i've got what's your
game like what's your name
oh there i saw i saw you doing a i think
had an arm
uh something online yeah i did that was
i [ __ ] my neck i'm doing head and arm
chokes i did them so much that i
i you know because you use your neck so
much with head and arm chokes
i developed like a real kink in my neck
and uh
turned out i had a bulging disc and uh
you know
so you do it on that just one side well
it was
uh no i could do it on the left side but
i definitely am better on the right side
the right side was my best side so if
you were to compete let's say like
what's your a game
what would you go from standing up how
would you go to submission would you
pull guard would you take down
what how would you pass guard what's i
don't have good takedowns
i was not a good wrestler so i would
most likely
either pull guard or i would pull half
guard do you have a good guard yeah
are you comfortable being on your butt
on your back yes i'm very i'm very
flexible so i have good
my rubber guard is pretty good yeah i
have good arm bars and good triangles
off my back but
um i also have a very good half guard
but my top game is my best
i have i have a very strong top game you
have a hacker card
you have a preference of like what kind
of guard and how to pass that guard and
uh like yeah like is there a specific
game plan like you would you double
under hooks from half guard is the game
plan
for me if i can get double underhooks
from half guard i could sweep a lot
under hooks of what sorry the arms are
so half guard
double underhooks got it clinched to the
bodies suck the body into the
pressure and yeah massive pressure and
then
inch my way into a position we call the
dog fight and
inch my way to a position where i could
well get the person on their back
yeah that's what because you did show me
i still disagree with you about the thai
thing
um that you can choke so wrong so wrong
well it's not wrong with you with you
it's wrong because you you know i think
there's a system where
i i've i've have this thing madonna here
we're going to figure it out
okay but uh have a little velcro in the
back
let's see that's you're just not
cheating you're not you're the exact
that's cheating
uh yeah you did i i did feel when you
showed me uh i think you showed me the
rubber guard
because it's still a god that's a little
bit foreign to me i just felt
that you can immediately feel not with
the rubber guard just but the way you
move your body is
you're um like a shanji type of guy who
knows how to control another human being
so like some people are a little bit
more
i would say agile and technical like
playful and
kind of loose loose and they work on
transition transition
transition you're a control guy like you
know how to control position and
advanced position
donahue is the same way he's all about
control my game is smush
that's my game smush you grab a hold of
you once i have you why would i let you
go
that's my thought is like why would i
let you go i just want to incrementally
move to a better position
until i can strangle you but i'm much
more
into strangling people than anything
else yeah which is a great mma
uh uh approach for uh jiu jitsu
well too many people don't tap when you
get their arms
you know and i'm it's not i'm not
opposed to arm bars i love arm bars but
everybody goes to sleep yep and and
quit from pressure too i mean yeah quit
mentally
maybe yeah it's nothing like you can't
breathe you know if you got a guy who's
like a really good top game guy
and he mounts you and i'm a big fan of
mounting with my legs crossed
you know like a guard like a top guard
and so i can squeeze with both legs
smush and i'm just i'm just looking for
people to make mistakes and slowly
incrementally bettering my position
until i can get something locked up
yeah i love jiu jitsu though man i just
wish it didn't injure you
yeah you know jiu-jitsu was like if your
joints were more durable
they could figure out a way to make
joints more durable god i could do jiu
jitsu forever
yeah so much fun
you